I think the big difference between Iraq
and Vietnam,
I said after we lost and withdrew from
Vietnam,
they didn't want to follow us home.
I think it's very clear.
If you read bin Ladin Sarkar ways are
we're hearing these other people,
they want to follow us home.
They view Iraq as a stepping stone to
America,
so the dimensions of the conflict have
changed dramatically.
It's eerie in a way.
Some of the comparisons to the early
stages of the Vietnam War and the
strategy that was used and the Rumsfeld
strategy,
there were both failed strategies and
they were very similar and so the on the
ground that's a little bit eerie.
It was called search and destroy and
Vietnam.
They went out and killed bad guys and
came back to base.
That was what Rumsfeld was strategy was
doing before then we got General Abrams
says the head of the military in Vietnam
and they went out and they went out and
they secured areas and they stayed and
they allowed the normal life to begin.
That's the same thing that ha that we
know strategy in Vietnam under general,
in Iraq under General Patraeus.
We'd go out and we secure an area and we
patrol all the time with Iraqi military
and we don't leave.
It caused an upsurge in casualties.
They are now coming way back down
because the strategy is succeeding.
That happened with General Abrams to in
the Vietnam War that people ran out of
patience and demanded that we do nothing
else,
even though our troops had already
withdrawn from the in this war.
The question is,
will it get Baghdad clock and the
Washington Clark be the same and that's
not clear to me.
Although we have beat back the Democrats
effort to set a date for withdrawal is
shorter time ago.
It was last week.
I think the other part though that is
most heartening to me use America is
very divided about this war,
but none of us are divided in our
support of the men and women who are
serving in uniform and unfortunately in
the Vietnam war,
it wasn't like that.
So I'm proud not only of these young men
and women who are serving because of the
best of America,
but I'm proud of America in that we are
supporting these young men and women.
No matter how we feel about the war and
whether it's right or wrong.
I think it's.
It's something that's very,
very important and one that I can't tell
you how much
appreciate it.